how you doing Michael great really how
you doing oh I'm better for talking to
you I'll be very honest oh it's a fact
it's a fact you know two guys who've out
kicked their coverage personally just
chatting with each other on his national
sports show that's the way we roll you
know the way mate it's meant to be that
way
knitties how did the head Giants go from
Odell being traded potentially in
February to paying him like a
quarterback essentially in August how
did that happen Michael well I think
that you know Dell through no fault of
his own actually maneuvered himself into
unbelievable leverage once the Giants
took say Quon Barkley it made no sense
to trade Odell Beckham jr.
because by taking say quant Barkley and
not a quarterback with the second pick
they were pretty much saying gentlemen
and Shermer we're trying to win while
eli still here for the next two years so
they had to bring back Odell so you know
tells otherworldly skills played in but
the Giants might have traded them if
they took Sam Donald I mean it wouldn't
make sense because then you're starting
a rebuilding he's trying to get a new
quarterback ready
but with Eli the quarterback and they
take a running back who probably has a
shelf life of five or six years
well Odonis just sit back and and be a
good guy which he was and they had to
give him the money so he said he won't
be the highest-paid player in football
that didn't work out so it becomes eyes
paid wide receiver in football and why
not he's in the same breath as Antonio
Brown and and Julio Jones you know you
know if you say third okay if you say
second okay but they had to give him the
money and how popular is he in New York
Michael berry rich if you go to a giant
game at MetLife Stadium and you remember
you used to always be Lawrence teller
jerseys that's right ah now it's all
number thirteen all the kids especially
he is super popular with the kids I
don't know if he's really unbelievably
popular with the older giant fans but I
just think that's the way the world is
right now he probably doesn't float
their boat but for every kid every kid
wants to be Odell Beckham jr. is he the
face of the Giants or you could
definitely say is the hair of the Giants
but is is he is either face of the New
York Giants
now Michael do you think oh I mean
part of me always thinks the quarterback
is the face but you know Eli standing
resting face isn't great a combination
of Eli you know darling and I think take
one Barclays gonna be in there too I
can't wait to watch him play I just
cannot wait to watch I mean we were
talking on the show yesterday after this
was this went down that Eli and Odell
and say Quan Barkley after the triplets
if you will in Pittsburgh that you'd
have to say that's the best receiver
quarterback running back combination
with Atlanta's potentially in that mix
Michael yeah I would agree and and let's
not forget Shepards a good player and
angler Matt a really good first year a
tight end
they've got a lot of weapons but you
know the one concern if you watch their
first three games a preseason they're
not gaining any ground with that with
that offensive line I mean it's still a
work in progress it's all new people
you've got Hernandez you've got sold or
you've got flowers move to the other
side these these are all significant
changes and the the biggest run they had
was the first carry by Singh Quan you
know 31 yards but 39 yards but since
then Stewart's been awful Gulman that
has been better but not great so that
offensive line better be good are those
those weapons don't mean anything
because if Eli's not gonna get any time
he's gonna have the same problems he had
under Mac adult Michael Kay joining me
here the Michael Kay show every single
weekday in New York City and then of
course the voice of the Yankees on YES
Network we'll get to that in a second is
Sam Donald is starting for the Jets
correct I mean that's that's it's all
but official would you agree it's all
all but official but I don't think
they're gonna make an official front
because they're probably still holding
out hope that they could get a higher
draft make a big trade Teddy Bridgewater
and if they could sell to people you
know he might still be the starter and I
don't think that would be the worst
thing I really don't rich I believe in
Sam Donald but there are three games in
in 10 days to start the season that's an
awful lot to ask of a kid that's going
to see new schemes and stunts on defense
that he
it's not seen in the first three games I
think it has the potential to be an
outstanding quarterback but it wouldn't
hurt to have a veteran start the first
three games no I know they do have a
Monday night game against Detroit to
start the season and then the Jets after
that in week number two take on Miami at
home before there's a Thursday night or
in Cleveland but all that said I mean I
mean you use all those draft choices to
go up to get them you're lucky enough to
get him period and and after all these
years you're just gonna sit him that
makes big gotta just go with him and
grow with him and growing pain with him
and just get it out of the way and maybe
just maybe they've struck gold in the
same way first year quarterback
performed say in Houston last year or
with Carson Wentz even in year one they
didn't make the playoffs but it was
still very successful you saw some
bright spots Michael I would think
that's the way to go and really starting
Bridgewater might even open up a
Pandora's box that you don't want to
handle because if he's great he's just
25 years old and then you know you've
been a Jets fan forever what the cries
gonna be so it's probably just best
dealing with the smart maneuver by
mechag ninh it just cost money and you
could get back graphics that you traded
to get Donald so and also you know we're
a giant camp and and Eli said it's
really important for a quarterback to
play in the first year he said if you
hold them back and say that you're gonna
he's gonna learn well what's he learning
because then the next year is this first
year I think it was important for Eli
Kurt Warner played nine games in my
blood Eli in and he was terrible he said
but if I had not done that the first
year I might have been terrible in the
second year so I think Donald has to
play this year a significant amount so
before up before I let you go Michael K
how many phone calls do you get from
Yankee fans who are flipping out despite
having a team that is third let me get
the exact right number here 35 games
above 500 but six and a half games out
which it's it's become distressing to
the point where I'm almost like immune
to it now but you cannot believe how
many people hate booing they think he's
a tear
I mean these are the same people that
hated you already so nobody's going to
be perfect for them and if you look at
the amount of injuries you watch the
games with your kids every night yes I
do
there's significant injuries and I think
the only thing that colors this is as
what people perceive as a less than
great season is the Red Sox are having a
record-breaking season but the Yankees
on pace to win a hundred and two games
and a lot of their fanbase is still
upset and they don't like the way
Boone's done the job and I think booths
done a very good job they want more fire
out of Boone but what they don't
understand is when you have a guy like
Girardi who was best described as a
clenched fist you go to the complete
other way that's why they went from buck
to Joe Torre and they went from Torre to
Girardi and they go from Girardi to
Boone they want a guy who's not going to
freak out that the players are not going
to freak out because he's freaking out I
think he's done a very good job has he
been perfect no he makes some mistakes
at the bullpen but again it's a working
progress that'll make the playoffs and
you know I think they're gonna go on as
a wild card and if they win that
wild-card game rich then they're right
where they wanted to be obviously their
main goal this year was to win the
American League East and it's gonna be
very difficult to do it they've got a
shot but I'd say it's a really really
long shot I think I think they're a good
team and that they could get that judge
and Sanchez then they have a chance to
win the World Series and what is the
scoop with judge what is the scoop with
him you know what he still doesn't have
range of motion where he doesn't have
pain rich and you know that's that's a
concern so you know they thought he
would be back in three weeks which was
ridiculously optimistic and it's a
broken bone it's not like a sprained a
sprain or a hamstring pull of something
like that the bones not healed so until
he has full range of motion without pain
he can't swing a bat so until he starts
to swing a bat he can't play in any
riyadh games and they're running out of
mindedly games so let's say he's out
another two weeks all of a sudden he's
gonna have to get ready and simulated
games which is going to be very very
difficult so I don't think he's going to
be back for the West Coast trip I think
Sanchez will I think that didi will
I think that Chapman will not be back
for the the West Coast trip
maybe he'll be back after that because
that's a long trip it's three games in
Oakland three games in Seattle and then
three games in Minnesota so if they can
get them back after that maybe they
could get them ready for the postseason
but the one injury that they could
absorb is the Chapman injury because
they legitimately have three other
closers but it's been very difficult to
absorb the judging just injury because
there is no other iron judge on the
bench well I mean it's a good thing the
Yankees are heading to Oakland because
that's where Sonny gray is good Michael
at least there they got that opportunity
to do and on the road that was my way of
I guess swiping at the Yankee rotation
before I let you go is what what what
does that look like any playoff if they
are fortunate enough to get through a
one game or against either Oakland or
most likely Oakland right now as opposed
to Seattle what do you think well I play
that one game playoffs and you made me
make the decision although I'm not paid
to do that I think I might go with Jay
Happ which would surprise a lot of
people but I'm gonna give Severino more
time to get that slider straightened out
but I would say the rotation looks let's
say 1 2 4 7 Reno
Jay Happ and then according to who
they're playing either cc or Lance Lynn
but no Tanaka huh you're not gonna you
know put him on I'm sorry yeah Tanaka
settle in I blew that no it's alright
it's either gonna be Lynn you're gonna
have to choose between Lynn and Sabathia
according to who you play Michael love
chat with you as always thanks for
calling in man we'll chat again soon
family good we're good how about you
everything's good my daughter starts
kindergarten tomorrow so I'm really
getting old are you going are you
dropping her off yes I am fantastic that
is great enjoy who colors better you or
her
who can color in between the lines
better you or your daughter Michael I'm
extraordinary color well you do
play-by-play I don't
I understand what you meant thank you I
appreciate love you Michael Kay we'll
take it well chat soon
love you back rich bye that's Michael
Kay the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience